My name is Gary Stevenson former trader and
people's economist this is gary's economics
today we're going to talk about housing
okay so there's 5 areas we're going to cover
about housing - number 1 why is it so expensive
no.2 is it gonna get more expensive
no.3 how that affects people
no.4 who's winning and who's losing
and no.5 what can we do about it
so we're gonna go right in with number one
why is it so expensive? now a lot of people
tend to believe that the reason housing
is expensive is because of the housing
planning policy in the local area - a lot
of people here in London believethat
but the expensiveness of housing is
not aLondon specific problem
so i used to work in thecity
with people from all over the world
people in Sydney, Australia think housing is
expensive because of the local planning problems
people in New York think that,
people in Los Angeles think that
people in Tokyo think that, people in Shanghai
think that, people in Hong Kong think that
people in Vancouver and Toronto think that
basically in all of the big cities all over theworld
you know i could keep going Mumbai, Rio DeJaneiro
everybody thinks that housing is expensive
because of the local planning policy in that 1 city
once you take a global perspective and you
realize that this is happening in most if not all
of the major cities in the whole world we have to
accept that the expensiveness of housing is not
because specifically of London planning policy
so it's a global issue housing globally is
expensive not in all cities obviously there
are parts of the UK where housing has remained
cheaper but in all the major cities it's happening
so why is this happening why is housing in major
cities all over the world becoming super expensive
well to understand that we need to take one
more broader step back and realize it's not
even just housing that has become expensive in
that same period of time the last 13 years since
the financial crisis most stocks and shares have
risen 400-500% much more even than housing
land prices have increased significantly gold price
has increased significantly even bond prices
have gone up basically the price of all assets
has increased significantly over that period
so when we understand this we can see that
it's not actually even specific to housing
so first it's not specific to london and
secondly it's not even specific to housing
what has happened is there's been a massive
increase in basically all long-term assets
all over the world so why has that happened
well if you watch my other video 'what is wealth'
and if you haven't watched it yet i recommend
you watch it - we talk about wealth inequality
increasing significantly and what that does to the
price of housing the price of stocks and shares
so basically in the last 15, 20, 30 years the period
where housing has become much less affordable
we've also seen a massive increase inthe share
of wealth owned by the very wealthiestpeople
the top 0.1% the extremely wealthy families
now when wealthy families own assets
that means they get a lot of income from the rest
of us because all of those assets give an income
and they tend not to spend that income they tend
to save that income so as inequality has increased
more and more income has gone from ordinary
people to the super rich and they use that
to buy assets that means we can expect to see as
wealth inequality increases a fall in the prices
of goods and services and wages because that's
what ordinary people spend their money on
& an increase in the price of assets, stocks, shares, land,
gold, other precious metals and importantly housing
and that's basically what we've seen as we've seen
inequality, wealth inequality that is, increase
significantly we've seen a massive increase
in basically the price of broadly all assets
and that's because purchasing powerhas
moved away from ordinary people who
buy goods and services which drives your wages
and towards very wealthy people who buy assets
so if that's what's happening inequality
is pushing the price of assets up including
housing and goods and services down why
haven't goods and services prices fallen why
haven't wages fallen well that's because there's
basically two effects going on at the same time
firstly increasing inequality pushes house
prices up and wages down but secondly at the
same time since 2008 central banks all over the
world have been massively increasing the amount
of money in the economy they've been printing
huge amounts of money pushing into the economy
i talk about this a lot more in my videos on 'Covid-19
and money printing' and when central banks print
a lot of money that pushes the price of everything up
so we've got 2 things happening at the sametime
on the one hand increased inequality pushes
house prices up & wages down on the other hand
more money in the system pushes the price
of everything up the net net balance is
wages & shop prices stay about the same and
house prices and asset prices go through the roof
so the expensiveness of housing is caused by two
things happening at the same time significantly
increased wealth inequality and it's important
to understand we're not talking about income
inequality this is not about doctors and lawyers
this is about wealth going to the super wealthy
families who own huge amounts of assets and at the
same time money printing wealth inequality pushes
house prices up, money printing pushes house prices
up, house price goes to the roof but at the sametime
wealth inequality pushes wages down so
the net effect is house prices go up and your
wages stay the same that is why housing is expensive
number two
is housing going to get more expensive?
short answer yes - if you watched my videos on
Covid you'll see that it has caused a massive
increase in both wealth inequality and money
printing that means we can expect to see housing
get significantly more unaffordable
and expensivein years ahead
now number three and number four
how does this affect you and who wins and who
loses now economists who often come from rich
families that own property like to think that
when house prices go up it benefits the economy
people see the house price rise they feel richer
they spend more money homeowners also often
like it when they see the value of their houses go up
but who loses out here? well the obvious group is
young people from poor and ordinary families
right people from rich families they can often
get significant deposits from their parents but
people from ordinary families when the house price
goes up and the wage doesn't it can become very
difficult or even impossible to buy a property
that means much longer in rented accommodation
which is expensive and if they are able to save
up a deposit then they'll have to take a much
bigger mortgage which will mean higher repayment
over a longer period of time so younger people are
losing the money every month because of this more
expensive house prices either through having
to pay rent or having to pay a bigger mortgage
when this happens they can easily respond by
thinking i've got to save up a lot more money
i'll have to spend less and that
can actually damage the economy
but let's talk about older people from ordinary
families who may already own their own property
right these guys often think that they're winning
when house prices go up but the only way that you
can get the money from the house price going up
is by selling the property now if you sell your
property and spend the money then that means you
can't give your kids money to buy their property
now we've already said that when house prices
go up that means kids from rich families can get
deposits from their parents but kids from ordinary
families can't and that means often they can't
get property at all so if you're a parent from an
ordinary family you own your own property you see
the house prices go up and you think you're richer
the only way you can actually get that money is by
selling the property and that's going to mean that
your kids and your grandkids will never be able
to own property at all so for ordinary families
they find themselves in a bind where they feel
richer because the house price is going up but the
only way for them to actually make that money is
to sell the property which will mean their kids and
their grandkids will never own property again
i can see this happening with the families around
me kids from richer families their parents are
able to remortgage their properties or access the
stocks and shares they have to give big deposits
to their kids and help them get onto the property
ladder but kids from poorer families their parents
need that money to help them get through
retirement and it means that kids from richer
families win and kids from poorer families end up
completely losing access to property forever so
the winners here are rich families whohave
a lot of property big portfolios of stocks
and shares which are also going up and the losers
are ordinary families who are losing their houses
so as ordinary families lose their properties
and kids from richer families able to buy them
inequality gets even worse driving house prices
up further still this creates a worsening spiral
which makes housing increasingly unaffordable
to ordinary people that brings us to the lastthing
(No.5) how do we fix it?
okay so what do we do? this problem is
caused by inequality so theonly way to
fix it is by fixing inequality not by taxingordinary
working people but by taxing the super rich
the government doesn't want youto
know this because it's run by people with
wealth of £100 million or even sometimes over
£1 billion - these people get huge amounts of
cash flows from us ordinary people to them which
they use to buy houses that our kids need and
often they do it whilst paying almost no tax
this can't continue we have to end it
push for wealth taxes on super rich people, educate
yourselves, watch my videos about Covid & Inequality
watch my videos about what is wealth
tell your friends, tell your mum, let's make it happen